the TA of Allah is you place a barrier
between you and the the T of Allah is
that you fulfill The Obedience of Allah
that which he calls you two the
obligations first and foremost followed
by the voluntary actions the T of Allah
is you keep away from the prohibiting
matters first and foremost away from sh
there after away
from Innovations and they after away
from sins disobedience
and the greatest good that you
enjoy is a and the rest of the pillars
and the rest of the
obligations and this is the case of the
[Music]
Believers the
Believers male and female are friends
and Protectors of each other what's the
first
characteristic they enjoying the good
and forbid the evil
so they enjoy the good first
characteristics of the Believers they
enjoy the good they forbid
evil the greatest good as we said
is to call to the worship of Allah subh
being sincere that which we say and do
say my prayer My Sacrifice my life my
death is for Allah the Lord of all of
creation submission to Allah alone not
to Creation being sincere that which we
say and do so the Believers their
characteristics is they enjoying the
good on themselves first first and
foremost then upon their families and
those around them they enjoy good and
they forbid evil upon them El first and
foremost and then their families and
then those around
them and they establish their prayer
look I heard him with my own ears he
said look how Allah mentioned in joining
good and forbidding the evil before
establishing the prayer and we all know
the importance
of establishing the prayer the second
pillar and the prayer in it is
[Music]
to say
Allah to glorify Allah and recitation of
the Quran that's how great the Salah is
it's great but in this verse Allah subh
mentions enjoying good and forbidding
the evil before the establishment of the
establishment of the prayer this shows
you that the people of andah they are
the on who enjoy good forid the evil
they are the ones who call the people to
all good they are the ones who start
with just like the prophets and the
messes they call to the worship of Allah
that is the case of the Believers they
call to the worship of Allah not to the
worship of creation they call to the
establishment of in the lands they call
to the rule of Allah you see lot of
the they think they're the only ones who
call to the rule of Allah they don't
call to of Allah in reality because they
don't establish the means to get to the
rule of Allah because the means to get
to the rule of Allah is also is not left
for you and me to make it up as we go
along no it is established by
the how to get that how to establish the
of Allah upon the land and that is a
gift from Allah that he gives to
you that is a gift to Allah Allah gives
you the means itself is
has to be the way
ofam so establishment of the role of
Allah must be in
ourselves and we call to that but first
and foremost we establish in
ourselves rulership belongs to
Allah rulership belongs to Allah he has
commanded none has the right to be
worshiped except Allah so so therefore
it comes under to worship Allah you must
follow the
messenger you must follow the of
Allah to worship Allah correctly you
must follow the way of the means to the
is the means to to reach your goal the
mean the means to please Allah the means
to worship Allah correctly the means to
establish the de of Allah upon the land
must be done according to the way of
the no by the because they say yes
belongs to Allah belongs to Allah but
they don't establish it according to the
way of that's why you find the they will
go around and say oh meah the state of
KU State
of the State of this shows you the wed
minds of these people and this shows you
also the misguidance that they upon
ignorance that they upon ruling belongs
to Allah yes but you must establish that
in your da by beginning with by
establishing the worship to Allah
subhana
tala verse 55
[Music]
Allah's promisees to those who amongst
you not all of you who believe in the
righteous Deeds that he will give them
the inheritance upon the land as he gave
it to those who came before
you and he will make their feet firmly
established upon the upon this
de that which Allah has made pleasing
for
them and he will change the state of
faar to that of
security what is the condition
so who's calling to the worship of Allah
correctly the people of who's calling
to Who's Calling away from the people
ofah who's
[Music]
clarifying with different
manifestations with your Libs who's
clarify that whoar
[Applause]
with the LMS is the people of Sunnah and
that's why you find them going
through because an excellent book shows
you and Sh whether it is by the Tongue
the heart or by the limbs an excellent
book
of of verses from the Quran
and which have supporting
narrations which have supporting
narrations clarify what
is an excellent book to go through it's
upon us to go through that book and we
found our teachers teaching
it
of yes people they go around these
Innovative they go around belittling the
scholars and they belittle this da but
this is the da that's moving forward
this is the da that's going from
strength to strength there's no stopping
it because Allah
will Allah is the Beloved of the
Believers those who have found this
blessing power
they are the ones who are calling to
they are the ones who calling to
obligations the pillars they are the
ones that establish the to Allah upon
this
[Music]
Earth 55 you can't escape it you can't
escape it because it's it's looking you
it's so clear the Quran from cover to
cover is clear the Quran is calling us
to and showing us the severity of sh is
calling us to those who call to the
prophets and The Messengers The Last of
them and he's calling and he's showing
us that that's salvation is and he's
showing us that's what
is
is is the strongest
handhold that is
the whereby if you upon thatan can't
can't defeat you Shan is is your enemy
you can't see
but he
hates and you find these political
activists they're not vising the people
with in his
book this is how taught the prophets
translated
by one misguided individual this book he
mentions ah there's two types of sh pces
no one proceed him saying this but this
is just to show you how these Pol
political activists go go about will
they take you away from he said there
two types of in this
book the sh
primitive and the sh mod the mod sh and
the Primitive sh the Primitive sh he
says the sh of call upon other than
Allah the sh of going to the Grave call
upon the Dead the sh they call that
primitive
old as if it doesn't happen nowadays as
if it's not occurring in different parts
of the world there are people still
doing around Graves still calling upon
the dead there are people that are
relying for other than Allah relying on
charms there are people going to the
magicians that seek help with the Gin
with
the this is all there are people
that are suffocated other than Allah
seeking help other than Allah in times
of EAS times of hardship this is all
happening he calls
it it's all
primitive but okay then what is the
modern day sh then come on let's get it
out of here the modern day
sh the of
the of the of the castles the sh of
rulers not ruling by not ruling by
Allah's La you see they focuses the
rulers but the prophet muham what did he
say
all of you are responsible and everyone
who's responsible is responsible to his
flock the ruler is responsible the man
in his house the woman in her house down
to the
servant all of us are responsible yes
the rulers are responsible and we are
responsible so why you just focus on the
rulers oh and that's why you find in
their lectures like Omar in the '90s he
he made a lecture meca the state of sh
we don't forget this we don't forget
history history is
important and we need to know history
because if you don't know history
history repeat itself you have to know
where these are coming from and you have
to know the first thing they do is
belittle the the scholars of ah they
Scholars for dollars ah Scholars scum
they call
them they put that on the on the face on
the front of the Masid the Masid of
Sunnah back in the days in is lon what
was the word scum s u m e s u m s c u
m SC n Scholars conspiracy undermining
Muslims that's what they call the
scholar scum well did the scum why
because the ones who in insult the how
could they be upon the great path okay
who are the then who are the scholars
you need to know who the scholars are
because indeed the messenger wasam said
[Music]
and indeed Allah at the head of the
century Allah will revive at the head of
the century those who revive the dean as
a whole and Allah will send at the head
of the century those who revive the de
as a home
[Music]
1400 who were the scholars at
1400 most of the these political
activist that were I mentioned in the
'90s
at the headend of the century they were
still in
school playing around they one of the
scholars at the head of the century
[Music]
H and their teachers like Hass he didn't
reach the head of the century not
Gregorian nor H he didn't reach any of
the head of the century so how can he be
from the scholars how can he be from the
Revival of this de Revival of this de at
the head of the
[Music]
century the
end
reving of IM Ahmed
1399 printed taken out of manuscript
from from and he taken it and
it's and it's printed 1399 before
[Applause]
[Music]
that before that 10 years
printed preserved the first 3 400 years
the is preserved the man preserved so
you know who the people of Sunnah are we
don't need to see storytellers and
listen to storytellers we don't need to
listen to somebody making a field
episode like East Enders we
want want that is where salvation is
salvation is not in a drama the
Salvation is going back to the de of
Allah the Salvation is going back to TAA
piety that is where salvation lies Allah
and Allah said that as we mentioned to
you and fear Allah that you may be
successful Fe of Allah to be
upon they get some people criticizing
this call just talk about we wish that
we live a life of day and night because
if you live a life of day and night that
is a life of success W that is a life of
success whoever
says 100 times a day
can it will be protection
Froman is powerful
that is
the how do you think the
messenger gave
gave so when did his book and he
confused tried to confuse the masses
alhamdulillah wrote his
book and you go through the Quran
beginning to the end you
see the da
of the first messenger isn't it the
first prophet was but the first
messenger
[Music]
was that they worship Allah and they
they be a pi good faing
and that they be obedient to Allah this
is of the first of
them who is people to worship Allah when
we used to see and
pray these political activist when
they
[Applause]
pray the obligations the conditions
first the pillars
and the obligations of the prayer you
don't just
pray without establishing the before you
pray do you face the you make sure you
have sit covering your covering your
body
your even to the extent that you have to
the messenger said let not one of you
pray except C
Shoulder sh nothing on your shoulder no
you should cover your shoulder we see
the prophet gave care toar to
Purity in 1995 he used to say when he
was teaching whoever wants then sit and
take
from of of
who famous
book
there in Inari and Muslim
great
book and likewise there is a excellent
book go
to go to the books
of because is two types Purity in what
which is your your
belief which is the tar to purify
Yourself by taking aath by
doing and Allah will raise you you be
Allah will protect you you be upon that
because this is first and
foremost and that is from piety
Allah Allah you believe Allah and
believe in his
messenger Allah will give you two of his
mercies protect you in this life and the
Hereafter as
[Music]
come and Allah place to you a light the
light of
guidance and he will forgive you and
that comes from first and foremost ta
and Allah said for those who want to
learn and want to benefit and Allah will
open doors for you you have to be Pious
you have to be good
fearing Allah and Allah will teach you
Allah will show you those who will Aid
you Allah will guide you to that to the
stent of knowledge will gu you to the
truth
what is the the foundation of piety of
ta is that the Ser mix between him and
that
which he's afraid of falling into
the a barrier that's the of barrier
between you and the because Shan is
going to come to you and me by two ways
doubts and
desires and sh how do you fight doubts
with knowledge beneficial knowledge
Allah said the messenger said
the and you take that
from ask people know knowledge if you
don't know sometimes some some
individuals they come on the YouTube
these YouTube shakes and they bring that
verse the curtain is open it's got a
baby face where for you to answer your
question no that is
not you don't ask this baby face
you they are the inheritance of the
prophets do not the scholars their
prophets don't leave
behind they leave behind knowledge but
the scholars gain whoever gains it gains
a great treasure the they are
inheritance the prophets and that's why
the none of the said that they that the
prophet praised the none of the said the
prophet wasallam praised these misguided
individuals called the these political
activists that their head is he's the
head wanted to share of
the he said to the
messenger Allah muhamad be just oh
Muhammad he wanted to share of the booty
and that's the case of
the don't be deluded by their
in first of all you tell them finish the
verse or don't bother with them because
the H is not with them we don't debate
with them we don't even listen to one
verse from them not even half a verse
from them because we're not in doubt
upon what we upon because we
met as the great scholars in the past
they used to say the great scholar
he said we met the scholars of M of
Egypt of which is mecah Medina that
Peninsula ah we met the scholars of
Yemen we met the scholars of sham which
is the current day Palestine Jordan
Syria we met the scholars of all of
these Scholars and all of them hold this
and likewise alhamdulillah we met the
scholars of the and in and in Yen the
lik
of and the likes and and the and the
scholars of Egypt from the likes of
muham who benefited and took Knowledge
from those who proceeded
[Music]
in
and the one who
explain all of these great Scholars who
had met the previous
Scholars
and who were the students of
who passed away and the scholars
of the likes of and the
of these great Scholars that
lived who was a teacher in
riy years and in for the three years his
neighbor he said the golden years they
were the
gold in in in Jed teaching after
Medina he won't tell us many stories he
said we
[Music]
met in Fr of
the there are men so you name your men
and we ask you name your men and he
start fluttering
uh then he said there
Allah's messenger
said they will not cease to be a group
upholding the truth clearly upon the
truth they're not hidden they're clearly
upon the
truth they will not be harm by those who
abandon them nor by those
who oppose them until the command of
Allah comes and they upon that the
scholars of they are clear they are
known
Muhammad yes from the scholars who were
teaching love that they had for each
other likewise who studied under the
great IMS in Medina studying under and
benefiting under
shead and he a and he was a colleague of
Muhammad and benefiting likewise from
the scholars that lived at that time the
scholars if I go to mention some of the
scholars names the likes
of likes
of the likes of in that
time at the likes
of SCH were known it is not they were
not
hidden you live under umbrella like you
live under umbrella you can't see up
Beyond it the scholars of are known and
they are known in every time they are
known so be with
them be with the truthful ones and they
are the people of you see you want to
Hast
the the want to
rush whoever Hast something before his
time he is meant by not reaching his
goal these te they rush and stop they
Hast and they're all over the place and
they cause more harm than good and the
messenger spoke about the and he said
they are the dogs of
the and he
said the worst of those are killed under
the
sky so these are going around and this
individual who says who they
call he going
went pra the
and they said Afters about only after
what trying to find whatever you can
find but you couldn't find it because a
scholar don't say that but after that
you go and sit with
a who says that
[Music]
and the theh
you are the most beloved piece of land
to me and if they didn't drive me out I
wouldn't have
left
said after the victory of of of makah
there is no after that and you call
it I
with I with he come I why because these
they need to learn with Allah you go
call the state of you go make Muslims
indiscriminately and I saw a post about
why all the rulers
are where's the ta ta means that you
don't speak except with
knowledge don't speak without knowledge
for indeed your hearing your sight and
your heart all of you will be questioned
about you don't speak except
with they are the people they are the
ones I should say they are the ones in
the know Allah said the messenger said
said Allah said the
M
said it is foolishness to compare the
statement with any else with the
statement of because the statement of is
unconditional it's accepted
unconditional
unconditionally ta necessitates that you
prepare for tomorrow what are you going
to prepare for tomorrow you're going to
prepare your your belief you're going to
prepare
your must be upon sincerity must be upon
the Sunnah this is what matters in might
grave Allah will ask
me these three questions of the Grave
he's not going to ask me about this r
that rer Allah Allah will send the
angels and ask you for these three
questions that's why it's imperative
wear even if you get to 50 60 70 and
you're still learning is not a problem
we don't believe they're not just Basics
is the that you need to pray yourself
until you get to your grave and you're
able to say Allah de in
Islam and this
man and we followed
him and said it's not going to be easy
to answer those questions if you're not
on it if you're not how easy he going to
say if you're not upon the how easy is
he are you going to
say that that this was the prophet who
came to call the people to H the worship
of Allah if you're going around like the
Su
saying Help Us messenger of
Allah the prophet
died said whoever mam he has died
whoever Allah he lives he doesn't die
these going around
saying Help
Us Allah saying in the Quran
[Music]
[Applause]
calling upon Allah call upon me Allah
says I'm
close don't call upon the the prophet
us when you seek help seek help from
Allah alone when you ask ask Allah alone
is
going no and some of them
all of these they calling upon others
besides Allah just like the time
of when he came and he called the people
they made images of righteous
men and they started worshiping him
instead of worshiping Allah they start
worshiping his righteous
[Music]
men worshiping them calling upon them in
the when the prophet Muhammad died
the sah didn't go to his gra help us ask
Allah to they didn't do which is
the didn't do
that they s to
Allah by calling Allah's beautiful name
this
is
but is you call upon others to seek that
is oh message of Allah help us ask Allah
to bring no sh
and Allah's Allah's messeng said that
Allah
said I'm free from those me whoever Comm
sh with
me a partner that he set
up besides me then I leave him and his
sh if Allah leaves you you're going to
be misguided
the one room you will return
to prepare for
tomorrow from py to prepare for
tomorrow look at the situation in
London one weekend of three days Friday
Satay Sunday over 100
stubing and some Muslims get Muslim get
involved in
Gs not all Muslims say some of our
children or the children of the
community get involved with gangs enough
is enough we have to go back
to purification and education get out of
these gangs and get out of these drugs
these are things that will harm the
community so how is it that you live
life a person says yeah I can make money
I can make money but only to destroy
other people's families that is what is
happening you may live large but
remember your accountability is coming
and how will you be able to live in
tranquility and you know your
accountability is coming you've messed
up other people's lives so fair in Allah
necessitates
education that we educate ourselves to
be sincere role models and gu in the
society it it necessitate say that we
cooperate with each other from TAA that
we share this blessed de we go and
convey it to the Far Corners of the
world we start with our city with London
and you can see London is a mess is a
mess with the underground and transport
all that but worse than that people
losing their de the people losing their
identity I'm a Muslim that should be
first and foremost because Muslim needs
to submit to Allah you're not submitting
to Creation you're submitting to the
worship of Allah we don't worship
Creations like all of these other
religions you got one religion
worshiping cows worshiping monkeys they
even said that the the cure for Corona
is in cow's D some of them or cow's
urine isn't Corona cured isn't and they
all just splashed in the cow's Dum and
yeah this is living
that is living that is cure cure is not
in that cure is go back to and Allah is
the
curer when Allah Wills that one is
Afflicted or one is tested with any harm
no one can remember him and you get in
the Christians those who believe that
the holy spirit is in them and they say
ah Jesus is a Son of God and then they
get confused who is God
then the father or is it the son who is
God they say no it's like fruit juice
you put the fruit juice together and it
becomes
one you give example of God as fruit
juice Allah is the creator of the
heavens and the Earth and you make a
mockery of of of your creator Thou shalt
not make any graven images of your lord
go into the church and you see all these
graven images that they make go to the
Vatican and you see that they make
graven images you go and in the church
itself the
priest probably more sinful than the
congregation and he's put hand over the
people say go my son you forgiven who
are you Allah is the one who
forgives Allah is the one who forgives
he's the one we turn to and he's the one
that's why there's a direct we don't
have priesthood in Islam we go direct to
Allah subhana tala and then the another
priest will come and say drink the blood
of Jesus gives you it gives you uh
pomegranate juice or it give you a piece
of bread eats the bones of Flesh of
Jesus
they not satisfied and they claim they
killed him now they want to drink his
blood and they want to eat his
flesh cannibalism that's not Islam
cannibalism somebody want to eat
somebody in front of your eyes you call
him a cannibal this is what's happening
in the churches and now uh everything
and everything goes in the
church H what happened to values Family
Values husband and wife what happened to
that a husband and wife and
children now it's become all confusing
to some people become very confusing
don't call me she I'm a how you think
one person how you think no don't call
me that otherwise I'll sue you you sue
me because I called you a she CU you're
a girl or I called him a he because he's
a boy it's it's
confusion the world has become a mess
you go to some countries which are more
liberal than others like Canada you see
people with orange hair pink hair green
hair they yeah I'm living this is living
all the color all the rainbow colors I
love to take
us that's the world we living in a a
world of confusion you keep your
identity because you know that's the
greatest thing that they trying to harm
you they they're trying to take away
from you the greatest thing that you
have is Islam the greatest thing that
you have is your religion is your faith
in
and you will see it one guy became
Muslim just the other day Christian
because I was really strong
Christian but I couldn't live it
anymore he said I see the Muslims going
to the prayer five times a day 3:00 4:00
5:00 they in the
m and they're praying Allah nothing is
greater than that because ta necessitate
Allah is the greatest in your life no
one is greater than Allah in your life
prayer time comes
I'm going to the
Mas there's nothing else more important
for me I'm going to bow down to Allah
and I'm going to prostrate to Allah the
Bible is full of those words and he fell
on his face and prostrated to his Lord
and he fell on his face prostrated to
his Lord and he fell on his face
prostrated to his Lord you see what the
Christians do nowadays Tamar organ
playing the Miracles all that dancing
twirling and then you have some of these
Muslims who claim to be have sh in their
lives and they're dancing around the
sufis when im Malik said when he was
said to there are group who are dancing
in they worship in the DI he said are
they
children he said to him now they are
grown men and he laughed all the way
home grown men dancing that's the DI and
and just recently I read a book I read
pass of a book excellent book
[Music]
he's got a whole book of over 400
Pages beautiful book and he refutes some
of these sufis and he says subh Allah
some of the sufis the sh is such a liar
and a and a fabricator of the and liing
to the people such a phoning is he
touches them is as if it's electric
current and they just you know shaking
and all of a sudden he drop on the floor
H next one comes electric current 220 or
more and he just ped on the floor
again he mentioned in his book he goes
Subhan Allah we had theam who was the
best of the worshippers and this didn't
happen we had
this the
best and that didn't happen when they
were the best of the sahab
and then they didn't used to go on this
this mode but you you get these
individuals the Sufi following the way
the
Christians these hot hospitals you see
them in America these evangelist the guy
touches him and it's like electric
current all of a sudden he goes and
flies the salf used to say don't believe
in these
innovators even if you see them walking
on uh on water don't believe these
innovators because we're not moved by
that or even if you see him flying
across see someone fly alhamd the people
of if we see some flying across this
this Hall that wouldn't move us you fly
and then fall afterwards but for us
don't move us
us bring me bring me bring me the
understanding the companions is no one
that can defeat all of these groups
except the people of Sunnah that's why
the is and we don't fear them and that's
why all of these groups the 72 that are
destined for the Hellfire because of
what they called to as the messenger has
mentioned in reced
by great recording
this of
splittings due to the numerous reps that
H what moves us is Allah said the
messenger said the sah United upon don't
bring
me oh yeah one of
the or one you know if you claim they
claim one
compion that's if he did he going
against going against the Sunnah it's
possible for someone to make a mistake
that it did that's why we say Quran
so don't put wool over our eyes the
already clarified this to us and they
already established theah and they
negated the they already established the
de of Allah upon
Clarity upon Clarity not for someone to
come lately and then say ah and start
speaking about the
companions if they bring any attention
and even if they
do someone schol Earth companion Earth
it could be he gone against the sunah if
that's the possibility if it was true or
he went around against the because it is
from the that we follow even the of
Allah names and attributes it is the we
follow he said we met all of these
follows all of them this
plural when they unite they upon
the his excellent
book it's impossible is is for to unite
against the when they unite is
the fire prepared the
disbelievers is fire prepared for the
disbelievers because they sh so when you
follow the disbelievers in the you're
heading for
that you will surely follow those who
came before you the Jews of the
Christian you will follow them hands
span by hands pan arms leg by arms if
they were to go through a li you would
follow them so fair day you will return
to Allah keep away from doubts and
desires what is the desires going to do
for you in this D 2 minutes 3 minutes 5
minutes you're going to get on the high
come back down again in the end you're
going to go back to Allah you mess up
your life what's the point sins are
destructive keep away from sins keep
away from Disobedience be righteous keep
ties of kingship keep up your prayers
five times a day and ask Allah for his
ask Allah for his guidance keep your
learning the dean of Allah learn learn
and learn you know like
some say to you brother don't study
don't don't read don't read
[Music]
read in that order read it read books
of protect yourself and save
yourselves with knowledge and with
seeking Allah
fear Allah as he should be feared not
how you want you want to fear him we
don't make it up as we go along we're
not allowed to the Christians make it up
as you go along we're not allowed to do
that it's the fastest growing religion
in the world alhamdulillah
Islam but we need to be upon correct
understanding the correct understanding
piety comes with it knowledge and action
sincerity comes with love for
Allah love for the The Last of The
Messengers Muhammad The Last of The
Messengers we love all of the messengers
what is it that
Jesus Son of Mary what did he say this
crad in his
cradle that's what we have to be
abdd Allah raised and he raised all of
the prophets and Messengers because they
were may Allah make us true sincere
worshipers of Allah this deal is no
stopping it it's going from strength to
strength and it will surpass many other
ways may Allah give us that strength to
be upon
[Music]